it's April 21st and you've tuned in to
gamespot news I'm Chris waters here to
tune up your video game knowledge with
the latest gaming news and I'd sing you
a tune but we're running a little short
on time and besides I really just wanted
to say tuna bunch it's fun word to to
tun tun tun there's your tune let's do
the news there are some characters in
Mortal Kombat X that you can play
against but not play as but that might
change players have been hoping for news
about story mode only characters like
Baraka rain and sindel and in response
to a question on Twitter about them
series creator ed boon responded quote
you mean like a story pack Oh newbie
you're so cheeky no concrete
announcement has been made but come on
it's gotta happen two quick stories for
you pc gamers today one those tiny
screwdrivers make your hands look huge
and to your fan is dusty I'm just
kidding that those things are true but
they're not the news first up a sizable
patch has arrived for GTA 5 PC fixing
things like facial features transferring
improperly between council saves and a
bug that could delay quick restarts of
heists for the full notes check out the
article up on gamespot com / news and
secondly WWE 2k15 is actually coming to
PC later this spring it'll be a special
edition with all the console stuff plus
the console pre-order bonuses plus the
console DLC all included in the purchase
price it's a quote pretty awesome deal
according to the guy who's on the cover
of the game John Cena who also notes I
was such a huge pc gamer that i bought a
living room entertainment system just to
play pc games back in the day more like
you can't see me cuz i'm stuck at home
all day updating my drivers on my ride
gamers
we're just under a month away from the
release date of the witcher 3 wild hunt
and you can get an exclusive look at the
mat from the open world epic in a video
posted to gamespot Daniel Dwyer and Andy
Bauman have some great preview coverage
up that'll whet your appetite for the
game unless like me you're already fully
wedded and that's a wrap for the news
today time to make like Hillary and get
back to playing Tetris on the Game Boy
maybe gray scale and poorly backlit but
i still think she'll make a great
candidate for more news go to gamespot
com / news have a great day and that's a
wrap for the news today time to make
like Hillary and get back to playing
Tetris on the Game Boy maybe gray scale
and poorly backlit but i still think
she'll make a great candidate stay tuned
Topher I don't think unless like me
you're already fully wedded
haha